welcome to Hannity tonight broadcasting
live we are in beautiful Bedford New
Hampshire where we are tracking several
major breaking stories tonight as we
speak
all eyes here on the Granite live free
died state and that is the first primary
polls will open in just a few hours and
meanwhile down the road in Manchester
president Trump wrapped up yet another
massive rally we're gonna take you there
our own Lauren Jones has been in the
crowd all night and earlier today yes
yours truly
I made a surprise visit to what was a
tiny I mean it C bit C sparsely attended
Biden campaign event kind of depressing
sight to be very blunt and many in the
audience through buses they were bussed
in and a lot of people there when I
talked to them they weren't even
supporting quid pro quo Joe it is kind
of there for the entertainment here's a
preview and it gets very interesting
what went down take a look
joe biden's on tape saying you're not
getting a billion dollars unless you
fire a prosecutor who's investigating
his son has no experience in oil gas
energy or ukraine and yet he's getting
paid millions and millions of dollars is
that okay with you I have no no comment
I think that's a red herring to red
herring to take the concentration off
what Trump is gone chuck was just
acquitted for life I know by a Senate
that was you're not answering my
question
yeah I'm sure all of your sons and
daughters are gonna get millions of
dollars just to get paid for doing and
knowing nothing with no experience that
happens to all of us right I guess if we
hit the lottery I will have the full
tape coming up it's very entertaining
but first we are only 267 days until the
election you will be the ultimate jury
you have an opportunity to shock the
world once again and this is political
crunch time the Democratic Party we can
report tonight is in an utter state of
complete shambles it is a mess the Iowa
caucus a total of mitigated disaster the
field of 2020 Democrats so weak so
radical so extreme many party insiders
are now actually freaking out on the
outside seventy seven-year-old quid pro
quo Joe is
supposed to be the fresh new face of the
Democratic Party look at the three older
let's see
a Bloomberg Biden and Bernie Sanders
that's like 500 years old combined he's
supposed to be their frontrunner but
after a pathetic fourth place finish in
Iowa his campaign is flailing and the
polls here in New Hampshire not looking
good either over the weekend a very
agitated and frankly well again
incoherent Joe snapping at a 21 year old
woman attending one of his town halls
not the first time he's been snapping at
people that he's asking to vote for him
she dared to ask a question about the
Iowa caucus and electability he said you
can't make this up that the young woman
had a dog face and called the woman 21
year old woman a liar
great job Joe take a look so how do you
explain the performance in Iowa and why
should the voters believe that you can
win the national election it's a good
question number one I was a Democratic
caucus at Mendel caucus no you haven't
you're a lying dog face pony soldier you
said you were but now you got to be
honest I'm gonna be honest with you it
was a little bit confusing in Iowa first
he says I am an Iowa caucus why it's
just like Joe 303 302 a 21 year old
woman you're a lying dog face pony
soldier supposed to be the Democratic
Party frontrunner it's really connecting
with the folks with the people we the
people the people that he wants to vote
for him that's their top candidate this
is now the third time that quid pro quo
Joe was caught on camera being rude
nasty to voters he said that he was only
joking didn't look like a joke to me but
the 21 year old college student at the
receiving end of this rage
well she's not laughing tonight in fact
she is insulted that they are pretending
this was some big funny joke she said
that quid pro quo Joe humiliated her and
quote he has been performing extremely
poorly in the race and the fact that he
couldn't just answer a straight question
with
bullying or intimidating just
exacerbates that fact she's right and
earlier tonight our own Griff Jenkins
was able to interview this 21 year old
student let's take a look frankly when
he speaks a lot of what he's saying
seems to be really pay post face and
very sad we have heard a lot about
deaths and cancer and people losing
their jobs and to me he doesn't really
seem very solution oriented and how we
fix those problems I don't think he has
the momentum to carry this to a national
election all right not exactly a good
look for someone who at this point
probably needs every vote he can get now
of course the campaign has more cause
for concern than Biden's deranged
rantings that are frankly unhinged there
are now dozens of legitimate questions
about zero experience hunter and a shady
business dealings not only in Ukraine
but China and other countries and then
quid pro quo Joe's Ukrainian shakedown
remember you're not getting the billion
dollars 1 billion dollars less you fire
that prosecutor investigating my zero
experience son Wow what quid pro quo Joe
doesn't have any answers to that
question every time he's asked all we
get is indignant rage and of course the
media mob never pushes them take a look
and Lindsey Graham told CBS News the
Justice Department is vetting
information from Rudy Giuliani about
your son's work in Ukraine are you
concerned a federal investigation maybe
already Giuliani are you concerned a
federal investigation are you are you
concerned do you think your son is fair
game here his son or my son your son
hunter I don't think I don't think our
sons are fair game at all no one has
said he's done anything wrong except the
thug Rudy Giuliani come on Rudy Giuliani
character witness in the same Rudy
Giuliani who nearly died on 9/11 became
America's mayor and was there to lead a
country that Giuliani the guy that went
up against the mob and became one of the
toughest prosecutors in history the guy
that turned New York City which was a
dump into going from what 3,000 murders
a year or thereabout to 300
same rudy guiliani yeah okay he's
controversial but it doesn't answer the
question Joe how does your zero
experience son no experience in Ukraine
energy oil or gas get millions of
dollars and how is it you used leverage
I'd even argue shook down the country
Ukraine and said you're not getting a
billion less you fire him you've got six
hours son of a B they fired him really
would you act that way if it was Donald
Trump and Donald Trump jr. anyway Joe
303 303 fall and getting pretty nasty
and negative and even turning on his
Democratic opponents including this
brand new ad against poor mayor Pete
Buddha judge didn't exactly have the
best track record in Indiana take a look
in both Biden and Buddha judge have made
hard decisions despite pressure from the
NRA Jill Biden passed the assault
weapons ban through Congress then he
passed the Violence Against Women Act
and even when public pressure mounted
against him and former mayor Pete fired
the first african-american police chief
of South Bend and then he forced out
that african-american fire chief to
we're electing a president
what you've done matters after days of
vote counting Oh mayor Pete apparently
was the big winner out of Iowa if anyone
believes those numbers and as the Biden
ad points out he struggles with
minorities didn't look too good over the
weekend in that debate now he fired
South Bend's very first african-american
police chief he forced out the
african-american fire chief as well and
during the last pathetically boring
unwatchable democratic debate and i only
watched it so you didn't have to and
this wonderful audience of ours he
couldn't even answer a question about
why he oversaw a massive spike a
minority drug arrest during his time as
mayor of South Bend and mayor Pete might
be seeing a surge in the polls but he's
not exactly popular with even his own
constituents
he's now battling for first place here
in New Hampshire in the primary with
congenital liar Elizabeth Warren and
crazy Bernie Sanders pretty angry
socialist